Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit
about Matt Gates. Republican Congressman
Matt Gates from Florida, we know is being
investigated for all sorts of different things,
including potentially child sex trafficking.
We have a new report which tells us that
Matt Gates could be charged as soon as July,
meaning as soon as next month. This is a report
from ABC which says, Since federal prosecutors
obtained the cooperation of Congressman Matt
Gates is once close ally in May. Sources tell ABC
News the ongoing investigation, which includes
sex trafficking allegations involving Gates, has
engulfed the tight knit central Florida political
scene as prosecutors continue their investigation
of the Florida congressman. Former Seminole County
tax collector Joel Greenberg, who reached a plea
deal last month, has been assisting federal agents
in the sprawling probe that has recently revved up
its focus on alleged corruption and fraud stemming
from Greenberg's time in office and beyond.
Multiple sources familiar with the matter told
ABC News. Sources told ABC News that prosecutors
believe a decision about whether or not to bring
charges against Gates could come as early as
July. We believed we were getting closer and
closer to a possible charge. Ultimately, it will
be a decision which may be charges. It may not.
That seems to be exactly the direction that
it's going, sources said. The probe into
the congressman has ramped up in recent weeks.
Investigators have started interviewing more women
who were allegedly introduced to Gates through
Greenberg, who last month pled guilty, pleaded
guilty to sex trafficking, a 17 year old girl who
later went on to work in porn and introducing her
to other adult men. Since May, a new round of.
Target letters and subpoenas in the wide ranging
investigation have been sent out. ABC News has
learned. So first of all, just what's already been
reported is a lot. But now that we are seeing that
there are multiple women that are being talked to
and we are seeing how long it's taking for this
to go forward, they may be building an incredibly
significant case against Matt Gates. We know
about Greenberg and we know about Greenberg's
knowledge of Matt Gates's activity. And I still
am unconvinced, by the way, that Gates won't end
up relatively unscathed. So on the one hand,
feds typically charge when they have a really
strong case. We saw this with a lot of the people
involved in the Trump Russia probe, Roger Stone,
Michael Flynn, et cetera. These cases were
ironclad by the time they actually led to charges.
They may be are being extra cautious because if
they're going to charge a sitting congressman,
you know, it's going to be highly politicized.
But at the same time, because it is Matthew Gates,
I just wonder whether there are really going
to be serious consequences for this guy if he
is indeed charged. Last thing, Gates may not even
be the biggest fish here because ABC is reporting
that as the Gates investigation ramps up,
feds are mounting a sweeping probe into
the central Florida political scene. So this could
also be much bigger than just Matt Gates. We know
some people down in Florida who are familiar
with Gates and follow this much more closely.
They have essentially taken this approach when
I talked to them, which is this is Gates is one
piece of a much bigger pie. It may not be names
that are as known as Gates. They'd be people that
are more known in central Florida. But there is
the suspicion that this could be a much bigger
I mean, crime ring almost sounds too
conspiratorial, but this may be a bigger
series of connected crimes than simply Gates
and Greenberg. So this may be even bigger. And
without a doubt, we know what the responses are
going to be. This is all political. This is all
a witch hunt. This is just like Russia,
Russia, Russia on Trump. It's just like
the impeachment hoax over the perfect phone
call. That's the approach they're going to take.
The feds go forward when they have really close
to ironclad cases. So maybe by July we will know